bye bye rue amherst voici la rue a tâté
kent dans la langue d'oc prononcé ada
des gones qui signifie frères et soeurs
l'apprenant ce rôle comme ils veulent
au final je pense que c'est normal quand
on a le nom d'une rue dans une langue
différente qu'il faut s'adapter
mais pour moi belgique genre pratiqué la
date et ghosn le nom et ma approprié
atotech on vous l'a dit tout tout notre
relation on parle pas de jeu canadien
québécois on parle de l'humanité eux non
plus rassembleur que celui du général à
minsk qui a conquis morial en 1760 et
qui reste est tristement célèbre pour
avoir distribué des couvertures
contaminées à la variole destiné à
exterminer les autochtones l'esprit de
nos ancêtres qui ont péri sous le
général amherst peut maintenant reposer
un peu mais aussi jusqu'aux maintenant
sur la nouvelle rue ada des gones
les passants approuvent très beau
changement pour réunir les gens puis
effacer l'histoire dégueulasse n'oubliez
pas qu'il faut qu'il y ait un
rapprochement
c'est bien sûr tout ce que ça représente
c'est un beau message donc c'est mika
moeurs montréal a beau avoir été fondée
en terres autochtones leur place dans la
toponymie de la ville reste encore
marginal sur environ 6000 toponymes
certains qui en a beaucoup des toponymes
à montréal on peut en compter une
quarantaine sont d'influencé autochtone
d'autres noms pourraient s'ajouter à
travers cette grande démarche de
réconciliation commencé sur
l'administration coderre pour son 375e
la ville a déjà ajouté le grand pin
blanc sur son drapeau pour rappeler la
place des premières nations
c'est en septembre que la rue amherst
deviendra officiellement haddad est
grande sur les pancartes du centre-ville
ici jean-sébastien cloutier radio canada
montréal